trauer und entsetzen in halle am tag
nach den tödlichen schüssen und dem
angriff auf eine synagoge steht fest es
war ein rechtsextremistischer
terroranschlag erdogan warnt die eu weil
brüssel die militäroffensive in
nordsyrien kritisiert droht die türkei
millionen flüchtlinge nach europa zu
lassen
ehrung für europäische autoren der
österreicher peter hunt für und die
polin olga tokarczuk erhalten einen
literatur nobelpreis für die jahre 2018
2009 10
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend eben ein zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
donnerstag an meiner seite ist für den
sport norbert lehmann ein schirm unter
familie bei unserer geschichte darf so
etwas in deutschland nicht passieren so
innenminister seehofer heute in halle es
sei eine schande für unser land
nur weil die tür der synagoge dem
attentäter standhielt ist der anschlag
auf jüdisches leben in sachsen anhalt
gescheitert trotzdem gab es zwei tote es
hätten sehr viel mehr werden können
eine klare einschätzung kam dazu vom
generalbundesanwalt auf einer
pressekonferenz mit der justizministerin
was wir gestern erlebt haben war terror
nach unseren erkenntnissen hat der
beschuldigte stephan b gestern sich zum
ziel gesetzt in der jüdischen gemeinde
zu halle in der synagoge von halle an
der saale ein massaker anzurichten
der 27 jährige hatte sich mit selbst
gebauten gewähren und sprengstoff
bewaffnet
heute ist sehr viel klarer wie das
gestern in halle abgelaufen ist
eigentliches ziel des schützen die
synagoge dort scheitert er an der gut
gesicherten eingangstür auf der straße
erschießt er eine passantin
dann fährt er zu einem dönerladen
erschießt einen 20 jährigen nach einem
schusswechsel mit der polizei kann er
flüchten im 15 kilometer entfernten wie
das dorf kappert er ein taxi verletzt
zwei menschen durch schüsse
schließlich seine festnahme nach einem
autounfall nahe des örtchens werschen
andreas weise berichtet aus halle am tag
danach am mittag kommt der
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
an der synagoge auf die gestern den
anschlag verübt wurde
schweigeminute für die opfer nachdem
steinmeier sich mit vertretern der
gemeinde getroffen hat tritt er vor die
presse spricht von einem tag der scham
und der schande
gestern sind zwei menschen gestorben
[Musik]
ermordet von einem täter der
offensichtlich zu allem bereit war zwei
weitere sind verletzt worden
unsere gedanken unseren mitgefühl sind
bei den angehörigen
die geschichte mahnt uns die gegenwart
fordert uns wir müssen haltung zeigen
auch der bundesinnenminister kommt nach
halle aus seehofer verspricht mehr
personal gegen rechts bei den
ermittlungsbehörden und erinnert daran
dass deutschland aufgrund seiner
geschichte eine besondere verpflichtung
im kampf gegen den antisemitismus habe
die bundesrepublik deutschland hat in
der schule gegenüber der ganzen welt
abgegeben
nie wieder und gerade in solchen stunden
fühlen wir uns diesem schuhe tief
verpflichtet
der mutmaßliche täter wird per
hubschrauber nach karlsruhe zum
bundesgerichtshof geflogen
ihm wird unter anderem zweifacher mord
und neunfacher versuchter mord
vorgeworfen
für die hallenser ist auch der tag
danach nicht wie jeder andere
am nachmittag versammeln sich viele in
der innenstadt es geht darum trauer und
fassungslosigkeit zu teilen es macht
mich unglaublich traurig meint dass nun
meine heimatstadt so was passiert
fassungslos war gestern ein tag wie
jeder andere und dann passiert so was
wir konnten unser kind nicht abholen und
es war ganz schlimm
sie gedenken vor allem der beiden opfer
von halle einer 40-jährigen frau und
eines 20-jährigen mannes bei mir im
studio ist felix zimmermann aus unserer
rechts redaktion denn wir wollen über
das video des attentäters reden
der mann hat sich selbst gefilmt alles
live ins internet gestellt das zeigen
wir ihnen natürlich nicht um dem täter
keine bühne zu bieten aber felix wir
wollen darüber reden denn das video sagt
einiges aus auch die ermittler haben
daraus einiges erfahren über den man ja
es ist so dass der täter bevor er mit
seiner tat beginnt etwas sagt und zwar
sagt er dass er den holocaust leugnet
schimpft dann über masseneinwanderung
und feminismus und gibt dann für alle
probleme auf der welt den juden die
schuld
außerdem gibt es einmal die fest des
täters im internet dort gibt er als ein
maßgebliches ziel an möglichst viele
juden zu töten
und auch andere nicht weiße menschen
notfalls aber auch willkürlich andere
opfer das zeigt natürlich eine höchst
antisemitische gesinnung und
rechtsextreme gesinnung das manifest
zeigt auch dass der täter die waffen
selbst herstellte mit 3d druckern und
auch sprengkörper selbst produzierte
nach angaben der ermittler hat er vier
kilogramm sprengstoff dabei er ist 27
aus halle hat abitur und zwei semester
chemie studiert in welcher szene war der
mann unterwegs leben wollte er
beeindrucken
der täter richtete sich mit seiner tat
eine ganz bestimmte zielgruppe im
internet und zwar gibt es dort fuhren
die terroranschläge danach bewerten wie
viele tote es gab die dafür punkte
vergeben
dort wird zum beispiel der attentäter
von christchurch der im märz 1 50
menschen tötete gefeiert und es spricht
ganz viel dafür dass der täter von halle
diesen menschen imponieren wollte
wir haben es hier also neben dem klaren
antisemitismus und rechtsextremismus mit
einer weiteren dimension zu tun nämlich
der radikalisierung durch so
internetforen bei denen menschen
verachten punkte dafür vergeben werden
dass möglichst viele menschen getötet
werden wichtige informationen von felix
zimmermann vielen dank auch dass eine
drängende frage heute warum gab es keine
polizisten vor der synagoge in halle
obwohl die gemeinde ihren höchsten
feiertag begehen
wie sieht es überhaupt aus mit dem
schutz jüdischer einrichtungen dass da
deutlich mehr getan werden müsse fordern
nicht nur vertreter der jugend in
deutschland die bundesregierung hat das
heute versprochen christoph distel über
die konsequenzen von halle heute vor der
synagoge in berlin vier polizisten
doppelt so viele wie sonst man kann es
fast fühlen
erst dann ist etwas einschneidendes
passiert ähnliche vorsicht in frankfurt
am main 100 einzelner bogen gibt es bei
uns die großen schon lange rund um die
uhr von der polizei bewacht
den kleinen tut sie was personell geht
in halle war es nicht genug
nach auffassung von polizei es war
ausreichend das die sporadisch ich weiß
nicht wie ich wie oft vorbei gefahren
sind
die haben gesagt wenn man polizistin nie
sieht das heißt nicht dass polizei nicht
da ist
dabei habe man sogar mehr getan als vom
bundeskriminalamt empfohlen rechtfertigt
sich der innenminister
trotz dieser gefährdungsanalyse haben
wir schutzmaßnahme sechs gemacht und man
muss immer wissen dass es in den letzten
fünf jahren keine antisemitischen
gewaltdelikte mit besuch zu der synagoge
in halle gab jetzt dabei gilt für alle
synagogen mehr schutz dauernd das
wünschen sich die jüdischen gemeinden
denn das ist wichtig um auch den
menschen die zum gottesdienst kommen
wollen die sicherheit und das vertrauen
zu geben dass sie gefahrlos in ein
jüdisches gotteshaus gehen können
die regierung stimmt zu und sieht sich
in der pflicht wir müssen an der stelle
ganz deutlich machen dass wir unsere
jüdischen mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
deutlich besser schützen müssen
ihnen gilt unsere solidarität und es
gehört zu unserer staatsräson dass juden
in deutschland sicher leben können
aber das nur hinter verschlossenen türen
und sicherheitsmauern das allein kann es
nicht sein finden betroffene wie
jüdisches leben in münchen
in deutschland müssen noch viel mehr
sichtbar sein
die zivilgesellschaft muss wissen dass
es juden mittendrin gibt ohne angst und
das nicht nur unter polizeischutz
keine toleranz verhasst gerade auch in
der sprache hat die kanzlerin heute
gefordert denn hasserfüllte worte können
den nährboden bilden für gewalt und
terror aber wer ist für die verrohung
von sprache verantwortlich heute nach
den schüssen von halle weisen politiker
auch in richtung afd geht es empört von
sich weist andrea maurer aus berlin
an tag eins nach dem terror von halle
mischt sich in das entsetzen auf die
frage wie gesellschaft und politik mit
dieser tat umgehen sollen
dass wir den anfängen wehren müssen und
das bedeutet dass wir aufpassen müssen
schon bei der sprache denn sehr oft kann
es passieren dass aus worten taten
werden
der schütze von halle war wohl ein
einzeltäter
und doch ist eine debatte entbrannt ob
es für die tat einen geistigen nährboden
gab ein klima für hass und gewalt
politiker von union und spd sehen in
dieser frage auch die afg in der
mitverantwortung wenn ich mir angucke
wie in den letzten jahren schon eine
diskurs verschiebung stattgefunden hat
wie tabus gebrochen wurden auch von der
afb die mitten im parlament dafür sorgt
dass immer wieder gegen minderheiten
gehetzt wird gegen dagegen menschen die
anders sind gehetzt wird dann muss man
ganz klar feststellen
das mag vielleicht eine einzelne person
gewesen sein die gestern in halle dort
gehandelt hat aber der nährboden der es
über jahre vorbereitet worden
wir erleben neben den eigentlichen
gewalttätern auch sehr viele geistige
brandstifter in unserem land und dazu
gehörten vor allen dingen auch teile der
afd
wenn ich zum beispiel an budget her aus
thüringen denke der ganz gezielt immer
wieder im bereich auch des
antisemitismus unvertretbare thesen in
den raum gestellt hat die afb weist die
vorwürfe als infam zurück wir sollten
aufhören diese schrecklichen morde
parteipolitisch zu instrumentalisieren
ich glaube das ist falsch wir müssen den
antisemitismus bekämpfen und das tun wir
mit klarem handeln und nicht mit
vorwürfen
die innenminister wollen nächsten
freitag über die folgen des terrors von
halle beraten
es wird vor allem um maßnahmen im kampf
gegen hass gehen mit dem anschlag in
halle beschäftigen sich heute auch
maybrit illner und ihre gäste ab 22.15
uhr im zdf und im live blog können sie
die aktuellen ereignisse und
schlagzeilen jederzeit nachlesen unter
heute.de wichtiges thema heute auch der
türkische präsident erdogan hat schaaf
auch die internationale kritik an der
militäroffensive gegen die kurden
milizen reagiert er drohte die tore für
flüchtlinge nach europa zu
falls die operation weiter als invasion
bezeichnet werde
die türkei plant eine sicherheitszone in
die syrische flüchtlinge umgesiedelt
werden sollen erstmals überquerten heute
bodentruppen bei der stadt ak lhe die
grenze nach syrien mit whiteboard
berichtet seit letzter nacht überqueren
türkische truppen und hunderte syrische
arabische freischärler die von der
türkischen armee ausgebildet und
ausgerüstet wurden die grenze bei attac
unterstützt von großflächigen
artillerie- und luft bombardements
stoßen sie in das kurdische halte
nordsyrien vor angegriffen wurde dabei
heute auch kamishli die
bevölkerungsreichste syrische stadt im
osten der syrisch-türkischen grenze
wir haben zehn notfälle zwei von ihnen
sind in einem kritischen zustand
bislang sind nach syrischen angaben 30
menschen getötet worden mehr als 60.000
zivilisten fliehen aus angst vor den
bomben aus den ortschaften an der grenze
ins landesinnere staatspräsident erdogan
lobte vor parteifunktionären den ankara
heute die quelle des friedens genannte
offensive bei der schon mehr als 100
terroristen ausgeschaltet worden seien
sagte er
unter drohte europa wenn wir versucht
unsere operation als invasion
darzustellen werden wir die türen öffnen
und 3,6 millionen flüchtlinge zu
schicken
bei den kämpfen feierten kurdische
milizen aus syrien granaten auf das
türkische akcakaya dabei gab es nach
türkischen angaben zwei tote und mehrere
verletzte
die türkische justiz hat unterdessen
gegen dutzende journalisten politiker
und internetnutzer ermittlungen wegen
terror propaganda eingeleitet weil sie
den einmarsch nach syrien kritisiert
hatten
die linke hatte gegen den
bundeswehreinsatz im kampf gegen den esg
klagt und ist damit jetzt vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht gescheitert die
rechtliche begründung für den
internationalen einsatz sei vertretbar
so die richter auch die rechte des
bundestags seien nicht verletzt worden
die bundeswehr beteiligt sich an der
anti es mission mit
aufklärungsflugzeugen und
militärausbildern gibt es doch noch eine
wende im wachse drama irlands
regierungschef war hat sich heute mit
dem britischen premier boris johnson
getroffen und sich hinterher
überraschend positiv geäußert das
gespräch mit johnson sei sehr
vielversprechend gewesen sagte becker
nach dem treffen von dem es bislang nur
fotos gibt er halte eine praxis einigung
bis ende des monats für möglich noch
müssen aber etliche fragen geklärt
werden
frankreichs präsident marco hat die
künftigen kommissionschefin von der
leyen scharf angegriffen er macht sie
dafür verantwortlich dass die
französische kandidatin für die
kommission vom parlament abgelehnt wurde
wegen einer finanzaffäre er habe von der
leyen auf das problem hingewiesen sagt
marco sie habe sylvie goulard und
dennoch ausgewählt und sie dann nicht
ausreichend unterstützt
der mord an der 15 jährige mia in kandel
in rheinland pfalz hatte bundesweit für
entsetzen gesorgt ein afghane wurde
dafür verurteilt jetzt ist der mann tot
in seiner zelle aufgefunden worden
nach ersten erkenntnissen hat er sich
erhängt abdul d hatte seine ex freundin
im dezember 2017 erstochen
in den folgenden monaten post
protestierten immer wieder rechte
gruppen gegen die deutschen
flüchtlingspolitik
große freude löste heute wieder das
nobel komitee aus die eine musste mit
dem auto erst mal rechts anfangen der
andere war nach der nachricht ungläubig
bis gerührt so unterschiedlich
reagierten die polin olga tokarczuk und
der österreicher peter handke als sie
erfuhren dass sie beide einen nobelpreis
für literatur bekommen
für die jahre 2018 und 2019
im vergangenen jahr war die auszeichnung
nicht vergeben worden wegen eines
skandals um sexuelle belästigung und
mangelnde beschlussfähigkeit der
akademie jessica busche und natalie
steger über die beiden preisträger an
den rodel muss sich olga tokarczuk am
abend in bielefeld erst gewöhnen
ich weiß dass ich eine gute
schriftstellerin bin aber dieser
auszeichnung hätte ich nie gerechnet
ich muss völlig umdenken sie ist eine
der bekanntesten polnischen autorin und
meinungsstark viele preise hat sie
gewonnen nun der nobelpreis große
erzählerische vorstellungskraft wird er
von der schwedischen akademie attestiert
in ihrer polnischen heimat ist sie
umstritten bei nationalisten sogar
verhasst weil sie zunehmende
fremdenfeindlichkeit ausmacht und zu
toleranz aufruft und dann gibt es da
noch den literaturnobelpreisträger
2009/10 anecken und unbequem sein das
ist auch peter handkes mission 1966
debütiert er als theaterautor mit dem
stück publikumsbeschimpfung
der schriftsteller aus österreich gilt
als grenzgänger zwischen fantasie und
wirklichkeit schreiben ich seine
forschungs bewegung eine selbstbefragung
bewegung und da muss hier jeder mensch
ganz tief in sich hinein damit was
herauskommt alle seine bücher sind viel
diskutierte werke und sprachlich
brillant mit seiner meinung polarisierte
allerdings im jugoslawienkrieg irritiert
er die öffentlichkeit mit seiner
parteinahme für serbien bei der
beerdigung des als kriegsverbrecher
verurteilten slobodan milosevic hält er
sogar eine rede
für das kino hegt handke eine große
leidenschaft das drehbuch zum in wenders
film der himmel über berlin stammt aus
seiner feder
im kommenden jahr sollen ein buch und
ein theaterstück von peter handke
erscheinen
jetzt der sport norbert gestern abend
fußball spiel deutschland argentinien 22
ist das nur oder immerhin ein
unentschieden aber ich glaube stimmt
irgendwie beides nur unentschieden weil
die not elf von trainer löw in halbzeit
eins überraschend rasant und brillant
aufspielte und verdient 2 0 führte
und immerhin unentschieden weil in
halbzeit zwei argentinien den spieß
umdrehte und einem sieg sehr nahe war
seit heute hat sich die personallage
etwas entspannt marco reus gestern
geschont steht für die partie sonntag in
estland bereit löws not-elf mit vier
debütanten und einem starken sabri zeigt
eine ansprechende leistung zumindest in
der temporeichen ersten halbzeit nach
der absagenflut machen hochbegabte wie
kein herz auf sich aufmerksam
ein gelungener test mit
schönheitsfehlern der stark
ersatzgeschwächten auswahl wie musste
mannschaft ein kompliment machen
mit welchem mut mit wirklichem herz sie
eben auch gespielt hat so mannschaft die
noch nie zusammen gespielt hat mit
spielern die wenig erfahrung haben ein
undankbarer abends war es für torwart
festlegen an den gegentoren schuldlos
keine chance sich auszuzeichnen
und so konnte er auch im duell mit neuer
nicht pumpen mehrkampf finale der frauen
heute bei der turn-wm in stuttgart und
da hat wieder eine sportlerin alle
überragt mit ihren 1 meter 42 simon bald
aus den usa ihr sechzehnter wm titel
der superstar des frauenteams aus den
usa dominiert auch die titelkämpfe von
stuttgart simon weiß wird zum fünften
mal seit 2003 10 weltmeisterin im
mehrkampf die 22 jährige texanerin tod
wieder mal in einer klasse für sich
elisabeth seitz aus stuttgart
präsentiert sich so gut wie nie zuvor
höchstschwierigkeiten mit großer
sicherheit trotzdem reicht es nicht zu
einer medaille
platz sechs aber ist das beste resultat
der 26-jährigen im mehrkampf simone voss
aus köln wird zehnte und morgen
nachmittag an dem stuttgart dass wir im
mehrkampf finale der herren zu 6 ab 16
uhr zu sehen wir uns im live stream
vielen dank das wetter bringt morgen im
norden regen und sturm im süden sonne
die details hat gleich christa stück
claus kleber begrüßt sie um viertel vor
zehn
im heute journal und morgen ist dann
raster wieder hier
danke für ihr interesse haben sie noch
einen schönen abend und auf wiedersehen
ja guten abend heute war es nochmal
herbstlich wechselhaft ab morgen startet
dann aber der goldene oktober seinen
versuch denn dann liegt dieses hoch hier
nicht mehr südwestlich von uns sondern
südöstlich und dadurch wird der weg frei
für sehr warme luft aus dem südwesten
und so lassen die schauer auch heute
nacht schon im süden nach es klart auf
dann an den alpen nahe 0 grad sonst 4
bis 8 grad bei stellenweise nebel in den
norden kommen aber dichtere wolken mit
regen vom emsland bis zur küste bei 8
bis 12 grad
und so könnte der morgige tag
unterschiedlicher nicht sein nördlich
einer linie niederrhein nordbrandenburg
da ist es regnerisch und teils stürmisch
vor allem anders
daran schließt sich ein bewölkter aber
trockene streifen bis zum main an und
südlich des mains das spürt man kaum
wind und die sonne strahlt und so sieht
das dann insgesamt aus im norden gibt es
bis zu 20 millimeter regen dafür im
süden bis zu zehn stunden sonne und
dementsprechend sind auch die
temperaturen verteilt 14 grad an der
küste und 22 grad am oberrhein und diese
schafe zweiteilung bleibt auch noch am
samstag erst am sonntag und am montag
reicht dir ein bisschen auf und dann
haben wir richtige t shirt wärme von 25
26 grad